PFT Oh team Monday edition where we talk
about the things we didn't have time to
talk about during PFT live and we
already have have moved toward this
topic Chris discussed it briefly and we
said we would get into it in more depth
during PFT ot and it relates to the
corona virus and look there have been
various things we have mentioned to try
to get ahead of the curve try to get
people thinking about issues that may
come up and I remember a few weeks ago
saying hey it may make sense to have a
quarterback that you keep quarantined in
the event that your quarterback room
gets coronavirus and I had all these
people go nuts on me oh you're you're
living in your fears it's like I'm not
living in my fears I'm living in reality
if two guys test positive and they're
your quarterbacks and you got no weather
quarterbacks
you're screwed so you keep a quarterback
away from the team in the event that
that happens Oh last week Bruce Arians
the coach of the Buccaneer said he may
do just that
so you know what else may happen Shireen
and I were talking on Friday about the
possibility of splitting your team up
entirely lo and behold baseball's gonna
do just that
keep two aspects of the team apart from
each other
to prevent an outbreak infecting the
entire team and now this question and I
think it's a real question if you put
yourself in the shoes of a young athlete
do you expose yourself and this is
ridiculous I know but if you're a young
athlete an NFL player who doesn't want
to have your season derailed in October
November December January do you expose
yourself to the virus now get the
antibodies so you don't potentially get
derailed in the middle of the season
Chris look it's irresponsible it's
reckless I don't agree with it as a 55
year old but if I was 23 and playing in
the NFL I'd be at the front of the line
to do it do that that's exactly it Mike
and then that's why I brought it up on
the show today just because again I
think you know the mentality of most
players and we're seeing this even you
know all athletes across the board I
mean we heard this weekend the NBA
players had a little bit of rebuttal
because they wanted more freedom and or
land up so that just tells you that
they're not necessarily like you know
like you know
like oh my gosh Cobin 19 again I think a
lot of athletes are gonna go hey I'm
young I'm healthy screw Kovan 19 I want
to play and I don't mean to sound
insensitive I know how dangerous it is
I'm certainly still trying to be careful
for ones I love and I don't want to
really get it myself either but like at
some parts and some levels I want to get
it to be done with it not worry about it
but I think it's a real question and
this is where I wish the NFL in the NFL
PA would start like gauging interest in
this stuff having these conversations
you know it's like John Gurdon called me
at 26 years old and was like hey you
know we might need you to come down here
to Tampa right now and just get Koba 19
and maybe talk to him the team's never
gonna do it that's the time can't do it
it's got to be either way I can't
imagine I mean if a coach does it it's
it's blatantly wrong I'm talking about
somebody who just decides on they're on
the same the same mindset that gets
people to use peds right you use a PE D
to make you better on the football field
to allow you to recover from injury more
quickly so you can play the same idea
it's like the anti PE D I'm gonna go get
exposed to this so I have the antibody
which kind of works like I got you it
allowed me to avoid the virus the team
can't be part of that but I'm telling
you I can't 15 be part of it why why
can't the teams get in here let's get it
we're gonna keep you off quarantined
we'll have all the food and everything
you need but let's start that would be
let here that would be a potential
liability a PR disaster if a team would
do that because it's wrong for the team
to do it but if the individual says you
know what this may not be a bad thing I
mean there's a lot of people that want
to get the antibody test I mean I
whatever I bet that crud that I had back
in January and February
maybe I've already had it I want to get
an antibody test and find out I'll be
happy if I've already had it I think
that's my mindset you know it doesn't
knock you out of things going forward
because you no longer have to worry
about getting it right no I I'm with you
I did get the antibody test and it came
back negative and I was like boy I was
upset because I was going
man I was really sick in February I was
really hoping I had it and then I
wouldn't have to worried about it
anymore you know with my no spleen and
all those issues whatever it may be but
Mike like yeah yeah back to the point I
think it is real and I think like I I
probably would be you know one of those
guys like calling teammates you know hey
let's let's maybe we should get it
should we just get it find somebody how
we can get it and then maybe build up
the antibodies and move on something
like that you know now listen I
understand there's great risk at all of
it and everything like that but but
still I just think the mindset of a lot
of young healthy you know athletes is
going to be no fear of this this virus
and of course young healthy athletes you
know they have a certain short shelf
life of being able to play in the NFL
and really capitalize on what their one
of their greatest talents and lives are
which is playing football and their
athletic ability you know I think a lot
of the players are gonna look at it like
I'm not gonna I don't want koba 19 to
stop this I want to play football so I
mean I just I think it's a good combo
especially because they're convinced
it's not going to affect them that's the
kid they're viewing it in in very
pragmatic terms this isn't going to kill
me I'm young I'm healthy you listen to
the charlatans out there they tell you
you're absolutely fine you have no
chance of dying or getting seriously ill
if you're young it's no big deal go live
your life don't worry about it okay fine
somebody's gonna find out the hard way
that that's not true 100% at a time so
you've got yourself convinced you know
you're young you're in Vince we've
already beaten the odds anyway just to
be an NFL player I'm in shape I'm
healthy I'm gonna live forever as far as
I'm concerned right now yeah I'll get
this thing it's not gonna derail me and
and it also is going to ensure that I
can play the full football season
because what they're telling me is if I
show up positive for the coronavirus
they're gonna shut me down for two weeks
even if I'm perfectly fine well that's
bull crap I'm not gonna do that
just give it to me now I mean look I
don't know how many I'd say enough
players are smart enough and they they
understand what's going on that they can
do the math and you know maybe a team
doesn't have to come out and say you
should go get yourself exposed maybe the
team just tells them enough about it so
they start putting to a
two together and all it takes is right
and the team to figure it out and he
tells teammates and we're gonna spend
June and July finding a way to get
exposed to this virus so so we can't an
Outlook I don't know it's not like you'd
go to the doctor and say hey can you
give me some coronavirus but yeah you
know you find somebody who's got it and
you go get it from them that's what I
was kind of like going down that
wormhole where you stopped me when I
just said like hey if John Gurdon called
me or something like hey I need you to
be the guy that you know kind of leads
the charge here start calling some of
the guys on the team you know see if you
can get this done or whatever it may be
I dig okay coach yeah I'll make some
calls let's see if we can make this
happen
I would be but you're right I mean I
know the organization's are not gonna
want to get involved in this or do this
but it's only gonna take one ringleader
and maybe you're right maybe just so you
send out some of the right signals from
the coaching staff or the organization
just some of the right guys to where
they rally the troops are get it done I
don't know again these are things that I
think the NFL the NFL PA they really
need to think about let alone they just
maybe take a vote on who really cares
about the virus itself anyways like I've
been talking about my issues separate I
know I know it's a separate issue but I
just still I wish they would find an
answer to that too because that might
actually help this issue you know if you
said if you take a vote from the NFL
players and all of a sudden you realized
whoa 99% of our players don't really
care about this virus maybe that could
open the door to go all right maybe we
should give everybody this and see if we
can you know then get everybody would
know I know okay
legally it's not gonna they're never
going to deliberately expose the players
to it whether the players do it on their
own is a different issue and I'm not
saying that it's right again sitting
here right now I say do not do it but if
I was 23 and I was playing in the NFL
and I understood how this all worked and
with the mindset I would have at that
age I would go do it I guess what I
should say is to those players don't do
it you should not do it you could infect
someone else why are you going through
this you could get somebody in your
family sick you get somebody in your
family dead
do not play Russian roulette with
someone else's life yes that's where I
come down on this but but when
you consider the mindset of the young
athlete and Chris you've been talking
about this for weeks they don't care
they don't care they don't care alright
fine I'm not worried about this disease
give it to me now
so I don't have to worry about it
screwing up my football season I I think
guys are gonna think that but I think
it's it's important for both of us to
say do not do this and maybe the teams
instead of encouraging it with a little
wink or a nod
maybe the teams and maybe the league
need to be engaged in efforts to make
sure it doesn't happen I don't know what
you do to police it but I I think that
at a minimum now that's the problem by
telling them not to do it then you're
introducing the idea into their head the
idea may already be there look this
isn't an easy my buddies don't do it
don't do it no one should be
deliberately expose themselves to the
virus so they don't get derailed by it
later I I certainly don't want to advise
anybody to do it either you're right
this is all about what I feel like I
would probably be thinking or doing if I
was a 25 26 year old football player
okay definitely I think even right now
if I was a 39 year old football player
I'd probably still be having those same
thoughts I can't lie that would be the
reality of the situation let alone Mike
I mean you're right I don't want to see
anybody endanger anybody or get their
family members sick or dead or anything
like that but think about this you know
how did this some of the players on the
Broncos feel right now who they talk to
Mon Miller and they go well he seems
fine everything's good to him and he
doesn't have to worry about this thing
anymore
he's good in training camp he can just
go no not to worry about anything to
railing a season or whatever that may be
you know you get a few players to talk
to a guy like that yeah maybe they will
be less fearful to get it maybe that's
why some of the Bronco you know I don't
know it just did it's just an
interesting topic nonetheless well and
Von Miller made it clear that he
actually was scared when he had it and
there were things about it that really
affected him he said it was frightening
the breathing problems that he had so
maybe in Denver you got a guy there
saying you know maybe maybe it's come up
in conversation and maybe locker room to
talk about it but maybe they said hey I
should just go get this so I don't have
to worry about testing positive in
missing three weeks of the season
you'd have von Miller saying no you
don't want it you don't want it that was
the most frightening part he said going
sleep knowing my oxygen level could drop
and I could wake up and have to go to
the hospital so look now there again
just so we're clear there will be
players who are tempted to do this
hopefully they'll have no idea how to go
about doing it hopefully they won't do
it they should not do it but I think
it's realistic for us to say there's
gonna be a temptation to do it and there
may be some who actually do even though
we disagree with them doing it I think
we've made our point clear what really
goes on that's yeah look if if people go
through this moral dilemma of should I
put a needle in my ass because this
substance inside of the syringe is gonna
make me run faster and jump higher and
recover from injuries more quickly and I
want to be able to play football it's
the same mindset it is it's the same
mindset you're right I mean it's about
you know just putting yourself in the
best possible position to succeed now
you know one of them's cheating which
bothers me and you know that I'm not
again for that but I understand what
you're saying the correlation
nonetheless
and yes this would be hey put something
in my body to where I know I can go
through the year and have one less thing
to worry about demanding me football is
hard enough with injuries and everything
like that I don't want to be thinking
about oh I could be at copán 19 in a
week six and then miss a few weeks of
games either so it is and I would I'm
with you Mike I think some players will
you know kind of tussle with this in
their brain and of course as I've been
saying for weeks I don't think a lot of
players are truly scared of copán 19 as
is anyways well we'll see how it all
plays out but these are issues that will
continue to be a significant for the NFL
as we see crowds out and about people
living their lives people not wearing
masks people thinking that wearing a
mask is in some way an infringement on
their rights the reality isn't the
Surgeon General said this over the
weekend it's not infringement on your
freedom wearing the mask ensures that
you'll be able to exercise your freedoms
because you'll be able to leave your
house because we won't be back in a
lockdown if people wear the damn mask
when they leave the house I mean I'll
tell you what somebody's gonna catch me
on the wrong day and give me a dirty
look when I'm wearing a mask and you
know if I wasn't 55 I might punch them
in the face
and if I wasn't going to jail I might
punch them in the face yeah I'm listen
like I hear you you know that I'll say
this up here in this area since I think
it got we got hit so hard because in New
York City a lot of people are still you
know being very careful and smart by
wearing the mask and listening to the
professionals but yeah every now and
then I got to go into a store or do
something I'm wearing my mask and you
see that person who walks in real quick
without a mat you just go and they do
they look at you weird you go you're a
jerk you don't care about yourself
anybody else in society you know I'm not
wearing the mask cuz I'm worried about
me I'm doing outta respect of other
people and other people who might be
endangered if they do get the sickness
I'm at a point where you know like I
said I'm almost like welcome it so I
could stop stressing about it but I
don't understand that part of the
society right now who's like looking at
you like you're weird
no you're weird for not wearing the mask
and we're seeing people die and all the
states that have loosened the guidelines
we're seeing numbers go through the roof
again
so what's getting scary so you know we
just got to be smart and I think some of
us are not necessarily being smart all
the time I try my best when I see
someone at the store not wearing a mask
and not make a face right I trauma I've
tried to look you you're not gonna wear
that it's not I can't make you you you
you're not gonna wear a mask I'm not
gonna say anything nobody I'm not gonna
start anything but don't give me a dirty
look cuz I'm wearing the mask don't give
me the dirty look as I'm doing the right
thing you're the butthole for not
wearing the mask you're the one who's
being insensitive you're the one who's
being selfish and you're upset because
I'm infringing on your ability to not
care because I'm the reminder that
you're doing something you shouldn't be
doing don't give me exactly because I'm
reminding you of something that you
should be how dare you remind them that
they're a jerk how dare you you're a
jerk for reminding them are a jerk I'm a
jerk anyway so I don't care that's it
for today's PFT ot we'll be back on
Tuesday with another edition of PFT live
check us out all day long a pro football
talk calm Chris great stuff is always
great fighting through the technological
difficulties get your iPad fixed and
tomorrow it's more fun when you're upset
all the time
screw you thanks Mike see you later see
everybody's video
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports